Друзі, всім привіт! З ваших коментарів я зрозумів, що ви хочете знати
більше про "Баумшулє" - німецькою - школу дерев.
ьогодні я у школі дерев "Лей" у місті Меккенгайм.
Саме вона постачає дерева для міста Бонн.
Подивіться - 500 гектарів, і всі вони засаджені деревами!
"Баумшулє" -  це розсадник десятків тисяч дерев,
де протягом 12 років їх загартовують або, як кажуть німецькі спеціалісти,
"навчають" виживати. Поки рослини не зміцныють,
їх захищають ось такі пластикові насадки
від зайцыв та оленів - любителів поласувати ніжною корою.
Директор розплідника Крістоф Дірксен
пропонує показати всі етапи "навчання" дерев.
Йдемо у величезні ангари-холодильники,
де підтримується температура трохи більше нуля - тут зимову сплячку
проводять однорічні саджанці,
які виросли у цьому розсаднику з насіння.
Коли ми обрізаємо саджанець знизу, ми обрізаємо і згори.
Ми підкорочуємо коріння і стовбур,
і в підсумку ось що ми будемо "навчати".
Ось так цей же ж саджанець яблуні виглядатиме через чотири роки.
Правильне і вчасне підрізання і пересадка
сформували густе і товсте коріння.
Друзі, подивіться! Цій яблуні один рік, вона коштує один євро.
А цьому дереву вже чотири роки і його ціна - 20 євро!
Ось така арифметика. Далі з роками
дерево ще стрімкіше дорожчатиме.
Друзі, а це дерево на спецзамовлення.
Цьому бонсаю - 20 років.
І коштує він від двох до трьох тисяч євро.
Директор пересувається 500 гектарами розсадника на джипі.
Їдемо до місця пересадки чотирирічних дерев.
Важливо, що нам цього року пощастило з погодою.
Було достатньо опадів. Тож, нам не довелося багато поливати.
Я не є прихильником частих поливів.
Бо коли рослини не поливаєш, вони намагається самі дістати воду з ґрунту.
Якщо їх поливати регулярно, буде недостатньо коріння.
Це і називається "навчанням" рослин.
У розсаднику працює 110 садівників.
Крістоф наголошує на інтернаціональності своєї команди.
У нас працюють люди з усієї Європи, а може й з усього світу.
У нас є працівники з Португалії, Тунісу, Сирії.
Є ще один португалець. Однак є й німці.
У нас тут команда, і всі важливі.
Пан Дірксен розповів, що у нього навіть працювали українці,
і він у захваті від того, як вони кваліфіковано виконували свою роботу.
Директор "школи дерев" каже, що готовий ще приймати українців,
однак поки немає охочих. Польські садівники почали повертатися додому,
бо у Польщі оплата за таку роботу вже сягнула семи євро за годину.
У ФРН платять десять, тож за різницю у три євро
польські садівники вважають за краще працювати вдома біля родини.
Це друга пересадка саджанця за перші чотири роки його життя.
Ці дерева виростили з бруньки, прищепленої, коли саджанцю було два роки.
Щеплення - потужний інструмент поліпшення якостей рослини.
Тепер їх треба рівно висадити.
Водій трактора Себастіан тримає рівну ріллю завдяки GPS.
За робочу зміну  висаджуємо 6-7 тисяч дерев.
Треба витримувати відстань між рослинами у 2,5 метри.
Німеччина - один зі світових лідерів у виготовленні найсучасніших тракторів.
Однак на моє здивування - майже вся техніка у розсаднику
від американської компанії "Джон Дір". Директор пояснює ситуацію.
Від "Джон Діра" ми отримали найкращу пропозицію.
Добрий трактор, за добру ціну ще й з топ-обслуговуванням тут у регіоні.
З висоти пташиного польоту видно, що всі дерева на цьому гектарі - однакові.
Коли ідеш величезню територією розсадника вражає те, що кожен гектар абсолютно інший.
За кілька хвилин поїздки можна побачити
всі стадії розвитку дерев за десятиліття.
Стенд ап. На одному гектарі в розсаднику ростуть 2500 таких дерев.
Подивіться, це червоний клен.
Різновид клену з червоним листям експортують і до України.
Аби дерево росло рівним, ще незміцнілий стовбур підв'язують і фіксують верхівку.
Друзі, я думав, що у працівників розсадника є якісь спеціальні прилади,
якими вони міряють рівність своїх дірок.
Перевіримо.
- Ну, що ви думаєте - рівно?
- Трохи вперед.
Що ж, це не так просто.
На шостий рік, коли дерево вже має міцний рівний стовбур,
треба регулярно шляхом обрізки формувати його крону.
Жозе керує підйомником, щоб піднятися на п'ятиметрову висоту,
і проріджує крону, надаючи їй акуратної пірамідальної форми.
Його завдання також вирівняти верхівку, аби примусити її рости вертикально.
- Скільки часу пішло на те, щоб навчитися це робити?
- Два-три тижні.
- Ви розмовляєте з деревами?
- Ніііі.... Це гарне питання, але не розмовляю.
У 1891 році Вільгельм Лей
заснував розплідник для фруктових дерев і троянд
в Меккенгаймі на ділянці землі розміром з футбольне поле.
Відтоді бізнес веде вже четверте покоління родини Лей.
Всі 128 років технологія "навчання" рослин вдосконалювалася.
Абсолютно загартованим деревом вважається,
коли йому виповнюється 12 років і воно пережило три пересадки.
Дерево кожні 4 роки виймають із землі, підрізають коріння,
підрізають крону і пересаджують на нове місце.
Це німецький стандарт якості, якого взагалі не існує в Америці або десь в інших країнах.
І саме ці наші внутрішні правила забезпечують те,
що зі ста доставлених дерев - сто будуть рости і далі.
Дерева з німецьких розплідників цінують по цілому світу.
З Меккенгайма рослини подорожують навіть до США і легко там приживаються.
Щоб не змарнувати десятиліття роботи, дерево треба правильно викопати.
Тут приходить на допомогу спеціальна машина.
Подивіться, чи не нагадує це вам кулькове морозиво.
Кулю землі з корінням одразу ж замотують у мішковину.
Далі затягують в сітку із залізної проволоки.
Така зручна форма крони і коріння спрощує транспортування
і надає можливість висаджувати ці дерева у щільно забудованих містах
між будинками в невеликі ями.
Раніше ми кріпили ремінь біля основи стовбура і "душили" дерево.
Тепер ця система дозволяє доставити дерево покупцям без пошкоджень.
200-кілограмова рослина злітає в небо і приземляеться на м'який матрац.
Крістоф демонструє, як компактно такі дерева
розміщуються у вантажівці, яка їх розвозять замовникам.
За рік з цього розплідника виходять 450 тисяч дерев,
"навчених" виживати в екстремальних умовах мегаполісів.
Друзі, пишіть у коментарях, що ще ви би хотіли знати про Німеччину,
і я обов'язково розповім про це у наступних серіях. Побачимося!